Even if you don’t know her by name, you
have most likely seen Frida Kahlo’s paintings
before.
She is the Mexican woman with a bold unibrow,
wearing a flower crown and brightly colored
clothing.
Kahlo was physically disabled her entire adult
life, and yet she loved herself enough to
be her own muse.
Years before her time, she challenged society’s
expectations, and was able to create Surrealist
works of art that examined the inner workings
of the human soul.
On today’s Biographics, we will tell you
the story of the great artist, Frida Kahlo.
The Birth of an Artist
Magdalena Carmen Frieda Kahlo y Calderón
was born on July 6th, 1907 in Coyoacan, Mexico.
Her family lived in a blue house appropriately
named; La Casa Azul.
Her father was a German photographer, and
her mother was Spanish and Native American.
Frida’s father used her as a model in his
photography studio, and it was during this
time that she learned how to be photogenic.
Even from an early age, she had an incredibly
intense gaze into the camera lens.
By the time she was 17, she was fed up with
wearing all of the frilly dresses that her
father put her in, and she chose to pose in
a man’s suit during one of their family
photos, which, of course, was completely frowned
upon in the 1920’s.
As a child, she suffered from Polio, and one
leg was permanently shorter than the other.
But she never let that stop her from being
adventurous.
She still climbed trees, danced, and played
outside with her friends.
In 1922, she began attending the National
Preparatory School in Mexico City with the
intention of becoming a doctor.
But when she was 18 years old, she was on
a bus heading to school, when it collided
with a tram car.
During the crash, a metal handrail impaled
her body, going straight through her torso
to the point where the rod was sticking out
the other end.
She had also fractured her spine in multiple
places, as well as a broken pelvis, hips,
collarbone, both of her legs, and a few ribs.
She had lost so much blood, the doctors did
not think she would make it.
By no small miracle, Frida Kahlo miraculously
survived the tram accident.
Frida laid in a hospital bed while her entire
body healed.
The doctor told her that because of where
the metal rod had impaled her, it was unlikely
that she would ever be able to get pregnant.
Even after several operations, she was now
disabled, and the injuries would still cause
her paint for the rest of her life.
Her boyfriend, Alejandro Gómez Arias, had
been on the bus as well, but he survived the
crash with only minor injuries.
When she wrote letters to him, she often asked
questions like, “What will my life be like
30 years from now?” and she knew that the
rest of her existence would be an uphill battle.
As you can imagine, her entire body had to
be put into casts, and she was not allowed
to leave her hospital bed for several months.
During this time when she was bedridden, her
father helped to set up a specially made easel
to hang over her bed, so that she could spend
her days painting.
Since she could not go outside, everything
Frida painted was from her memory.
She was painting her own Surrealist versions
of reality, along with symbols of Mexican
religion and culture.
Frida also painted and sketched herself, in
order to express how her pain felt through
drawings.
There is no doubt that even though her body
had been weakened, her mind was still incredibly
strong, and that helped keep her going.
Frida once wrote, “Feet, what do I need
you for, when I have wings to fly?”
As time went on, she chose to no longer groom
herself the way women were expected to.
She was trying to heal from the accident,
and there was no time to tweeze her eyebrows
or shave her upper lip.
When she painted “Self Portrait in a Velvet
Dress”, she kept all of those details true
to real life, even though she could have easily
painted out what society deemed as imperfections.
This level of honesty was incredibly brave,
even by today’s standards, when you think
about how many selfies are taken with Snapchat
filters and Facetune.
But at this point, Frida Kahlo was just happy
to be alive, and began to embrace the body
she was born with.
Once she left the hospital, Frida returned
to school, but she was now in a wheelchair.
While her friends were still spending time
with her, they wanted to continue living their
young, vibrant lives, and they drifted in
different directions.
She and Alejandro Gómez Arias broke up, and
she decided to focus on the life she could
cultivate, which was her mind, and her art.
So she join her University’s chapter of
the Mexican Communist Party, and it would
set her on course for the rest of her life.
Love
In order to understand the full story of Frida
Kahlo’s epic love, we need to go back to
when she was 15 years old.
A famous artist named Diego Rivera was painting
a mural in the Simon Bolivar Amphitheater
at the National Preparatory School.
Frida would sneak in to watch him.
She was fascinated by his work, and he completely
inspired her to become a great artist.
Like most teenagers with a crush, she swooned
to her best friend about how great he was,
and say that one day, she would marry him
and have his babies.
But then, when he left the painting to take
a break, she put soap all over his ladder,
and teased him when he slipped and fell.
This was enough for him to notice her, but
not enough to reciprocate her feelings, of
course.
After all, he was 35 at the time, and from
his perspective, this was just a kid who was
trying to distract him.
But he couldn’t help but notice that she
“had an unusual dignity and self-assurance,
and there was a strange fire in her eyes.”
Fast forward to 1928.
Frida was 21 years old, and it had been 3
years since her accident.
Through an intense amount of physical therapy,
she finally learned to walk again, but it
was still necessary for her to wear back braces
and corsets made of plaster, in order to keep
her spine straight.
Sometimes, the pain was still too much to
bear, and she would have to use a wheelchair.
She was all grown up now, and in the 6 years
since she last saw Rivera, she had become
a beautiful young woman.
Even though it had been years, she would still
visit his famous murals around the city, and
followed the progress of his artistic career.
She heard that he was painting another mural
at Mexico City’s Ministry of Education,
so she began to show up every day.
This time, she sat quietly and respectfully,
watching and studying him as he painted.
One day, Frida Kahlo bravely approached Diego
Rivera, and told him that she had admired
his talent for years.
She explained that she was an aspiring artist,
and wanted to know his opinion of her work.
At first, he did not recognize her, but once
she explained the story of the soap on the
ladder, he instantly made the connection,
because she still had that same fire in her
eyes.
Frida invited him over to La Casa Azul, where
he could see all of her work in her studio.
After seeing Frida’s art, he told her, “In
my opinion, no matter how difficult it might
be for you, you must continue to paint.”
While he was in her home, he could see how
much joy and passion she had for painting,
and it rejuvenated his love for his own work.
He said, “I did not know it then, but Frida
had already become the most important fact
of my life.”
They began to spend more time together, and
went on several dates.
A few days later, he kissed her for the first
time.
This was just the beginning of a relationship
that would last the rest of her life.
Diego Rivera and Frida Kahlo were married
in 1929, and they continued to be one another’s
muses.
Their relationship inspired one another to
keep creating more and more amazing works.
In one of her letters to him, she wrote to
Diego, “I’d like to paint you, but there
are no colors, because there are so many,
in my confusion, the tangible form of my great
love.”
Career & Communism
Frida and Diego were both part of a group
of artists and intellectuals who would later
be labeled as part of the “Mexicanidad”
movement, which was a re-invigorated sense
of national pride.
Instead of trying to copy European artists,
they wanted to create a new art style that
identified Mexican culture.
Aside from their mutual love of art, Frida
and Diego also discussed politics at great
length.
Diego was so-well known, that he became a
political activist in the Mexican Communist
Party, and was often painting Soviet symbolism
into his works of art.
Diego Rivera was already wealthy from the
sales of his art, and as the years went on,
the rest of the world was beginning to respect
and appreciate his Mexicanidad style, as well.
He was invited to paint several murals across
the United States.
At the time, no one was paying much attention
to Frida Kahlo’s work, because she was just
the wife of this far more famous artist.
In 1931, they were living in New York City,
and she was miserable with the vibe of the
town.
In a letter to a friend, she wrote, “I'm
not painting or doing anything.
I dislike the ‘high society’ here, and
feel a little rage against all these fat cats,
since I've seen thousands of people in terrible
misery.”
For years, Rivera was slipping Communist iconography
into his murals across the United States,
but they mostly went unnoticed.
In 1933, Diego Rivera painted a mural that
was meant to go in the lobby of the Rockefeller
Center, called “Man at the Crossroads”.
But he clearly included the image of Lenin.
Once they spotted this, the officials demanded
that he removed all Communist imagery, but
he refused to do so, and the painting remained
unfinished.
After spending several years traveling, and
Diego had an architect build them a two seperate
houses that were side-by-side and connected
by a bridge, so that they could live together,
and still have each of their own private art
studios.
Eventually, the couple returned to Frida’s
childhood home La Casa Azul, which she inherited
from her parents.
In 1937, they met the Communist revolutionary,
Leon Trotsky, who was living in exile.
Since they were already huge supporters of
the USSR, they invited him to live with them
in La Casa Azul.
For years, there was an ongoing rumor that
Frida Kahlo and Leon Trotsky were having an
affair.
She even gave him one of her self-portraits,
with a note that said, "To Leon Trotsky, with
all my love, I dedicate this painting.”
The rumor about their affair was published
over and over again so many times, it was
eventually taken as historic fact.
It was even included in the plot of the 2002
movie Frida, starring Salma Hayek.
However, it was later discovered that the
affair may have never taken place, after all.
In his last will and testament, Diego Rivera
strictly forbid any of his personal paperwork
to be released to the public until 50 years
after his dead.
He ordered that all of their private letters
and documents should be hidden inside of their
bathroom wall at La Casa Azul.
So, when they were unveiled in 2007, the public
finally got to read the letters between Kahlo
and Trotsky.
While it’s true that they frequently wrote
to one another and spent a great deal of time
together in their home, these hidden letters
reveal that the correspondence between Kahlo
and Trotsky was strictly platonic.
In fact, Frida Kahlo spent most of her letters
supporting her husband, trying to convince
Trotsky that he deserved to have a more prominent
role in the Communist party.
She even called Trotsky out on his behavior
as being egotistical, and revealed that she
did not like him at all.
She once wrote, “ I observed that whenever
there was a discussion of any kind, and Diego
gave his opinion, you always took it with
a certain irony and doubtfulness of its truthfulness.
This kind of irony in time gets on one's nerves”
Finding Herself
Throughout her life, Frida had to undergo
a total of 30 different operations.
One of her most famous paintings, “The Broken
Column”, depicts how she truly felt inside.
Since she was constantly in and out of the
hospital, she became very good friends with
her doctor.
There were a series of letters that revealed
that she became pregnant with Diego Rivera’s
child.
This came as a shock to her, since she had
been told that she would never be able to
have children.
However, her doctor urged her to get an abortion,
because he explained that her body would not
be able to take the pregnancy to full term.
However, the guilt of the abortion was overwhelming.
When she got pregnant a second time in 1932,
she tried to keep the baby, even if it meant
breaking bones and sacrificing her own body.
But the scarring in her uterus was too extensive
to bring the pregnancy to term, and Frida
suffered a miscarriage.
On one of her body corsets, Frida painted
the Communist symbol over her heart, and an
image of a fetus over her belly, to symbolize
the two unborn children she had lost.
She wore it like a medal of honor underneath
her clothes.
Since she was disabled and in near-constant
pain, Frida could not fully satisfy Diego
Rivera’s libido.
He was also a celebrity, so there was no shortage
of female attention.
Frida was fully aware of his infidelity, but
she had also become totally dependent on his
care, and addicted to his love and affection.
Instead of divorcing him, she took the opportunity
to have an affair with the photographer Nickolas
Muray, and she also experiment with her sexuality
by having affairs with several women.
She became good friends with the actress Josephine
Baker, and the artist Georgia O'Keeffe, who
was famous for making paintings of flowers
that actually look like- well...you know what
they look like.
Frida and Diego would often throw parties
at their home, and the famous Mexican musician
Chavela Vargas was invited to one of them.
After seeing Frida for the first time, Vargas
said,
“She was like a vision.
When I saw her face, her eyes- I thought she
was from another world.”
The two become very close, and had an affair
that lasted much longer than the other flings
she had with women.
During an interview, Chavela Vargas expressed
that she truly did love Frida Kahlo, and she
drew all of her artistic inspiration from
her.
Frida’s favorite song of hers was called
“La Llarona”, which is based on the terrifying
Mexican legend of The Weeping Woman.
However, Frida Kahlo was still in love with
Diego, and she was never going to leave her
husband for another woman.
This relationship of unrequited love was breaking
young Vargas’ heart.
She wrote the song “Paloma Negra”, or
“Black Dove”.
In it, you can clearly hear the anguish in
her voice.
Even though she claimed to be fine with their
mutual unfaithfulness, Diego Rivera crossed
the line when he slept with her sister.
Yikes.
They got a divorce in the year 1940.
One month later, she cut off all her hair,
and painted a self-portrait dressed in one
of Diego’s suits.
At the top of the painting, she included a
bar of musical notes, and the lyrics of a
famous Mexican folk song about falling out
of love.
Unfortunately, though, love is an incredibly
complex emotion, and it doesn’t just turn
itself off overnight.
She expressed her inner turmoil with a double
self-portrait called The Two Fridas, showing
her past self on the left, which was wearing
a white dress, symbolizing her past purity
and innocence.
The young Frida had her heart ripped out of
her chest, and she gave it to the Frida on
the right, who was older, and much stronger.
But she still held onto the memory of Diego,
by holding his portrait in her hands.
Even though she was clearly in a toxic relationship,
Frida and Diego felt that they could not live
without one another, and they got remarried
less than a year after their divorce.
There is a saying that great art comes from
pain, and in a way, this betrayal actually
helped to further along her solo career.
In 1947, the “Two Fridas” painting was
purchased by the National Institute of Fine
Art in Mexico City for 4,000 pesos, which
is roughly $1,000.
After modern-day inflation, that’s closer
to $11,399.
Finally, the art world was beginning to recognize
her talent, and she was no longer just the
wife of Diego Rivera.
Death, and Legacy
In 1953, Frida Kahlo finally had her very
first solo art exhibit.
But her health was declining.
She was so physically weak and in pain, her
doctor advised her to stay in bed.
Even when she was sick, her soul was still
strong enough to demand that she must go to
her art show.
That night, the patrons of the arts received
the grandest entrance they had ever seen,
as Frida Kahlo’s four poster bed was carried
in on a stretcher by a group of men.
She was all done up in a beautiful dress,
makeup, and a crown of flowers on her head.
Sadly, her illness got worse, and that same
year, she contracted gangrene in one of her
legs, and it had to be amputated.
Even so, she tried to stay strong, and decorated
her prosthetic leg to make it beautiful.
But she was already in constant pain from
her earlier injuries.
Losing her leg made it even more unbearable.
She learned how to walk again, and even tried
to go dancing in her new leg.
Her doctor prescribed her pain medication
to help dull her senses, but it was still
a life of near-constant misery.
On July 7th, 1954, she turned 47 years old.
Her friends and family threw her a birthday
celebration.
There were over 100 people there.
For the first time in months, she dressed
in her finest clothes, put on makeup, and
donned the flowers in her hair again.
But once the party was over, and the guests
went home, she was left alone to face her
reality.
Perhaps she knew that from then on, things
were only going to get worse.
Her health was declining, and she struggled
to accomplish even the smallest daily task.
Just a few days after her party, on July 12th,
Kahlo was lying on her childhood bedroom in
La Casa Azul.
She sketched an image of an angel with black
wings.
In her journal, she wrote, “I hope the exit
is joyful- and I hope to never come back.
-Frida.”
The next morning on July 13th, Diego found
her.
She died of a pulmonary embolism.
Most speculate that this was caused by overdosing
on her pain medication, and that she chose
to commit suicide.
Her family visited the home, and helped to
prepare her body, before it was taken to the
Palace of Fine Art for a public viewing and
funeral.
Diego Rivera was in such shock, he refused
to believe that she was truly dead.
He got into an argument with her doctor, refusing
to bury her until he had substantial proof
that she was truly gone.
Afterwards, they draped her coffin in a black
cloth with red flowers.
Diego insisted on draping the Communist symbol
over her coffin, as well.
Over the course of her lifetime, Frida Kahlo
created a total of 143 paintings, and 55 of
them were self-portraits.
She became the first Latin American woman
to have one of her paintings displayed in
the Louvre Museum in Paris.
She has become such a well-known artist, that
people simply refer to her as “Frida”.
Even though she is gone, she is anything but
forgotten.
Today, her work has become more relevant than
ever.
Her works and personal letters are considered
to be so valuable, that they sell for millions
of dollars at auction.
And in recent years, there has been a strong
resurgence of appreciation for Frida Kahlo,
and she has truly cemented herself in history
as a true Mexican icon.